[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast
live stream number 56.
am i correct about that wow that's a lot
of live streams it's so many live
streams it is
a lot of live streams so uh we are just
post thanksgiving
hope everyone irrespective of where you
are american
or not if you are american no matter
what population you come from i hope you
had a great
thanksgiving we had an excellent if
small thanksgiving here being
under fairly restrictive coveted
conditions
um but uh what our viewers don't know is
that you have uh
mastered the art of thanksgiving and you
make a
spectacular turkey and all sorts of
awesome things that go along with it
and anyway i look forward to it each and
every year
it's a great holiday and to the extent
that like america
it was born a bit compromised we should
do everything in our power to bring
everyone in
on it because frankly being thankful is
the key
to so much absolutely and we'll say a
little bit more about that
uh shortly one of the items we want to
talk about today
but we wanted to start by just
mentioning
that because many people have asked for
it
we now have dark horse products
available zach you can show this just
for a moment
um this is at teespring.com
dark dash horse doc dash podcast
um and you could find hoodies and mugs
and and such there so
um we'll we'll return to that at the end
of the show at the moment um
you can use the
code thankful to get 15 off and if
you're one of our patrons you can go
there to get 20
off through monday and when you do go
there we know what you're going to think
which is where the hell are the hats
and we are working on it that's
certainly what i thought yeah
our thought was that people who like
things like baseball caps have them
and so we initially skipped the hat and
did
other things like baseball bats we
thought about evergreen themed baseball
bats decided that would be tacky
but uh i didn't think that no all right
in fact that never came up
that's a total lie but uh no i mean i
think actually uh darkhorse themed
baseball bats would be
awesome awesome awesome but um
yes if you want a baseball cap so we've
already got one therefore you don't need
another one no
not really not so much it doesn't work
like that so they're coming uh soon
enough in fact they've just been made
available through this
remarkable mechanism in which we do not
have a garage full of inventory
store it up but somehow the things will
magically arrive at your doorstop if you
want their doorstep
if you want them or your doors stop
depending upon where they start course
branded door stops there it is
all right okay so you wanted to start so
we're we're going to talk today
about a number of things uh protests
politics consider the thinking of
christopher hitchens and milan kundera
and hopefully get to a little bit of uh
of talk about whether or not prehistoric
american
women were big game hunting alongside
men
which we alluded to a couple of live
streams ago and haven't gotten back to
but first you wanted to speak to a new
york times op-ed by david brooks that
came out today
is that right yes i did actually we have
it available zach is going to bring it
up on the screen he's going to scroll
down here a little bit and he's going to
put it somewhere where
i can read it because there's not a
chance i can read it at that distance
all right i'll see if i can read the
first paragraph here david
it is david brooks says
in a recent monmouth university survey
77
of trump backers said joe biden won the
presidential election
because of fraud many of these same
people think that climate change is not
real
many of these same people believe that
they don't need to listen to scientific
experts on how to prevent the spread
of the coronavirus and then he goes on
to describe
how one of the two political parties in
the united states has lost its freaking
mind
so you told me that this morning right
you came downstairs and said david
brook's got this new op-ed in which he
claims that one of the political parties
has lost its
mind and i said to you which one does he
think it is
which one right anyone's guess
especially given that it's david brooks
who you know
uh has never been an arch conservative
but certainly leans
right under normal circumstances or at
least under historical circumstances
and here he is in the new york times
which i don't even want to say at leans
left but it certainly leans blue
um and uh here he is suggesting that the
red team has lost its mind and that the
blue team is left scratching its head
over how people could be so darn crazy
appears the driven snow as well right
so anyway he goes through an argument
about the way that the
you know the internet is not playing the
role that people think it is playing and
the
and the fact of the red team having lost
its mind and all of that
um and he points to uh you know of
course he points to
uh so-called conspiracy theorists and he
points to
um theories like uh
i don't even want to call it that but
arguments like q anon
and the culture that has grown up around
it but
the problem here of course is that it
isn't one side he's not
wrong about the um the fact of there
having been
a uh a break with reality
on in certain quadrants on the right
what he's wrong about
is that this is in any way unique to the
right and there are certainly things
on the left or the blue team
that function in exactly the same way
and it's not even hard for us to you
know to go through a list in fact if we
spent a lot of time at it we could
probably
you know come up with a half an hour's
worth of topics to discuss but
you know the fact that many people on
the blue team
think that uh sex is not a binary that
that's a biologically established fact
that to the extent that there are
categories of sex that are even worth
our time that people can transition
between them
at will that they in fact can detect
internally that they are of one and not
the other and that their transition
is something that manifests a reality
underneath
at the age of three five seven three
five seven
people who i feel must never have been
three five or seven or they would
understand just how confused a state of
mind
those ages might lead you to have
um but people on the blue team also
believe
uh widely believe that um
that there is no biological content to
the concept of race that this
is entirely a fabrication now i'm not
arguing of course i'm not arguing that
there
are not people whose internal state does
not match their
uh their sex and that transition has a
an ancient root and that it is finding a
new
footing in modern times i'm not arguing
there's no truth to that i certainly
have argued many times that the concept
of race is not legitimate but it stands
in for one that
is legitimate population it's an
imperfect proxy
for population and it is both woefully
imprecise
and because of its degree of imprecision
and the way it is used it is actually
also inaccurate as a proxy
well in fact i'll go you one better and
this will
for those of you who are paying close
attention to the dark horse podcast you
will remember our
discussion of systematic versus random
error
now the fact is race is a bad proxy for
population
because of racist
tendencies which mean that the error
it's not just imprecision in the concept
of race
it is actually systematic bias that is
self-serving for the people in a
position to define it so
race is a thoroughly compromised term
but
that is not the same thing as saying
that it is a
biologically total fiction it's a
bastardization of something
so yeah no i mean this this this is
actually a point that i made a form of
back in
well it would have been 2017 in the wall
street journal op-ed that i wrote
in which i observed that it seemed to be
the republicans
bizarrely who were now standing up for
science and
as as brooks argues uh in that very
first paragraph of his op-ed today that
you read from
the fact of climate change deniers
being much more common on the right than
the left
has allowed this sort of persistent
fiction
that there are people who believe in
science and there are people who don't
believe in science and those
map cleanly along blue red lines
and in fact you know belief in science
isn't a thing that you should have no
matter what
you should have uh an interest in
pursuing the truth and understand that
the way to get there
is by careful and replicated use of the
scientific method
and under no circumstances should you
trust a result simply because
it fits with your previous model right
and in fact this
leads us to another place in which we
have a mixed result on the blue side
where i think the blue side has been
better in the early days of coronavirus
at figuring out
what it was about but it is amazing how
many people on the blue side
still believe that coronavirus emerged
from nature via a wet market
right so the point is this is just a
mythology now everybody acknowledges
that it didn't come through the wet
market and there is certainly reason
to be skeptical that it came directly
from nature in fact
i would argue that that is the much less
parsimonious explanation at this moment
because the beginning of the pandemic
did not start the way a zoonotic
virus would be expected to take off in
the human populations zoonotic meaning
coming from a non-human species
right which is not to say that the virus
isn't built of natural stuff but the
question is did it go through
a laboratory phase and so we can't say
that it did
but what we can say is that it is
unscientific to rule out that hypothesis
and that for many people who have looked
deeply into the question is actually
more parsimonious that it would have
come
from a lab leak than directly
from nature well some of what's going on
i think is that
the vast majority of people and really i
think all of us sometimes
feel extreme anxiety and and
nervousness if if the ground on which we
are walking metaphorically feels
unstable
if we can't figure out what's real
what's going to what has been real
it's going to be real and what this
can result in is a desire to get answers
quickly and then to stick with them even
if they proved to be not right
and so you know the early
gosh a little bit like the early days
after 9 11.
the early days of the pandemic were
really really hard
on everyone but it didn't feel nearly so
divisive
as it did you know in january 2020 and
before
or by you know june 2020 and afterwards
right
for a couple of months there there was
there was chaos and there was
um dissent and all but no one really had
a sense of what
all might be true and who could be
trusted
and um you know some of some of some of
that sense of
of unease was propagated by
by our president but some of it
was i think organic because we just
didn't know and still don't know a
number of things and because no one yet
had picked a side
we were all kind of in it together
trying to figure it out and we spent a
lot of time early on these podcasts
talking about that you know going into
the pre-print servers and talking about
this is this is so democratic like this
is what
this is what the results of science
should be should allow people who are
interested in and who can make sense
of this research that is being done to
go and say yeah actually
that headline based on this isn't what
it isn't what the research says or
actually this is a hidden gem and we
should be
focusing on this and um as soon as
people pick teams
then they become trenched in their teams
then you get tribal affiliation
and a real reluctance to change
and to take in new evidence even if that
evidence is something that
prior to picking your team even if it
was you know two days two weeks two
months ago
you would have been totally open to it
yeah and you know so
i think the thing is teams are natural
and normal
they can be healthy they can be
malignant yeah um
what can never be healthy is the belief
that there is nothing that exists
outside of the team dynamic
in other words the idea that we're going
to differ over everything and
we're going to pick this set of beliefs
and you're going to pick that set of
beliefs there ought to be an awful lot
of stuff that we just agree on right
like
it would be really great if we could
drive coronavirus to extinction
so that we could go back to doing what
we do well and figure out what went
wrong
and prevent it from ever happening again
that should all be non-partisan
and yet this has become this dynamic
where you believe one set of things or
another and it is very likely to align
with a bunch of other beliefs
which have nothing to do with it and so
you know
to continue down the road we've got many
on the blue side
who believe that the 2016 election was
hacked by the russians
right a story that absolutely collapsed
we have belief on the blue side that
either
there is no deep state or that the deep
state is
people who keep the lights on and not
something
worthy of consideration right when
there's a huge amount of evidence that
there is some sort of deep
thing which is involved in a continuity
exercise
that makes it unaccountable and we don't
know what it's up to
certainly in the 1970s 80s 90s it would
have been exactly the democrats who were
most likely to acknowledge
that such a thing existed absolutely
um so anyway the the amazing thing about
brook's piece is not that it doesn't
contain a piece of the truth it's that
it contains
what you know you close one eye and you
see
the brooks version of the truth and you
don't understand that if you look
through the other one
i mean it's a terrible analogy but um
but in any case the point is
there is a flip side and once you spot
that both sides are losing their mind
and that we are
hostage to some dynamic which is causing
us not to recognize the huge number of
things in fact the vast majority of
things
over which we ought to have very little
argument then
you know it is it is time to step back
and reevaluate because you know
you could write that same article from
the red perspective
and you know it matches in fact
something i've been saying
for i think at least 15 years which is
the fox news viewer regards the npr
listener as crazy
the npr listener regards the fox
news viewer as a fool and you know
at some level they're both right you
know that these perspectives
are um they are unnatural
they are scripted for political purposes
and you know the quicker we get a
majority of people that
stand outside of these things and see
the defects in both perspectives
the sooner we can get back to a sane
world
absolutely i wholly agree um
let's talk about some more evidence that
that's not the direction we're going
shall we yep um so the
protests that quickly turned into riots
uh that began in portland after the
death of george floyd in the end of may
uh have uh receded just a little bit
since the election um uh as as if it was
a
temper tantrum about trump at some level
um but not completely
at all which then suggests what what is
it what
what are you people doing so active
vandalism continued in portland
um even though the weather now here is
um
you know quite chilly quite wet you know
quite
not conducive to hanging out in a street
party
here's a story from the oregonian from a
couple of days ago
or actually just two days ago police
arrest three after protest related
vandalism in southeast portland they of
course uh
went after the local chain of
um excellent i think uh supermarkets new
seasons
and um say that they were protesting
quote colonialism
gentrification and capitalism this was
wednesday night
in specific um prelude to thanksgiving
because that is what they see the
holiday
as um thank you zack
um they're never gonna run out of
excuses
of course right so those those words
could
i should have and i did not predict that
they would have been the words used in
this case colonization capitalism and
gentrification
that thanksgiving represents according
to some process
protester that talked to the author of
that oregonian article
but the fact that they aren't going to
run out of reasons
that can fit any absolutely any scenario
does not answer the question of why the
adults in charge continue to let it
happen
what what could possibly be going on
here and
you know this i i don't want to be
talking about this again
but you be weak in the face of a tantrum
and then
be assured that the tantrums are going
to get worse in the future
of course they will if you've ever dealt
with a small child or especially if
you've seen
some other parent failing to deal with
the tantrums of their children it's
easier if it's not your own
and see them get worse and worse and
worse the kid get
less and less and less both controllable
and productive and happy
in the face of a parent who is is
weak-willed and makes
fake threats etc and there's just
there's
no good resolution down that road this
is about power
it's about power we should be listening
to them when they say that everything is
about power
and take it back from them they have
demonstrated that they're neither mature
nor wise enough to have power why are we
giving it to them
all right so we are giving it to them
i believe because you know we keep
running into the same
structure in stories that are so
different from each other that we don't
recognize it as the same
right we have a conflict between
the individual level and
the higher level of analysis in other
words governance
is the manifestation of our collective
interests or at least it's supposed to
be
but it's staffed by individuals who have
interests that make them
uh manipulable and can cause you to get
them to do things
that are actually bad for all of us
right so
the politician may understand in fact
that the right thing to do is to deal
with the protest but they may not want
to pay the price
of the person who makes that call right
we have
an okay but the election just happened
oh i agree if they were
they've got a little time here and um
yeah go on well i guess my point would
be i would agree
that if you were going to see a shift in
which
the collective well-being took
precedence over the individual survival
of the politician you would expect it to
be right after the election when
they have the longest period of time for
memory to fade before the next election
so the fact that we're not seeing it now
ought to scare the hell out of us
because it means
uh even under the best of circumstances
these people can't find their balls
and you know make the right call it's
also true that i am certain i do not
have the data to back this up but i am
certain that a majority of portlanders
do not want this garbage to continue
this this is this is not what most
people want
lots of people quietly will say i can't
believe this is continuing to happen in
fact
you know i interacting without people
knowing what my positions are not being
familiar with the podcast etc
um have had no one say you know good on
them
keep it up and everyone who has brought
it up say
this needs to stop i don't know where
our leadership is
well i i agree now i do think there's a
sampling
bias there sure is like i said you know
these are people who
don't know who i am i think but
obviously there's you know
there are circles in which i travel
right and you know just
by virtue of what one does in the world
at the moment the people you're most
likely to interact with are people who
you know have businesses and you know
things like although um you know retail
clerks i try to engage
um the people not just who are you know
who own the small businesses that are
still managing to stay afloat
um that we can manage to to to go to at
this point but
anyone who's ringing up a purchase who
presumably is you know not a small
business owner for the most part
right but even you know i'm i hate to
say this but even those people
you know have jobs they're working
towards something and so they're not
hell-bent on destruction
so you know it it's a it's but that's
the thing do you think a majority of
portlanders don't have jobs and are hell
bent on destruction no you don't
no i don't but but here's what i do
think is that the game theory that
causes a mayor to do
things that any rational analysis would
say are insane from the point of view of
what a mayor is supposed to accomplish
those same phenomena
structure the interactions of the public
because
the public of portland is involved in
signaling
its agreement that there is something
dire
about our you know racial dynamics that
this is having important
impacts on uh you know people's
well-being and you know to that
extent i agree but um but
the point is that active signaling and
in fact the
uh the positive feedback as people are
one-upping each other and signaling just
how
irate they are about these dynamics and
just how interested they are
in a solution is causing those at the
higher level at the
level of actual governance to be
paralyzed because they think they are
facing
um and you know an angry population
that is demanding these things and you
know that is of course
fueled by the fact that those people who
are breaking the law
are actively punishing anybody who
tries to say hey look this is
unreasonable right those people if you
say this is unreasonable you're a
fascist you're a nazi you're all of
these things
so what that means is there's artifa
from the point of view of the power
structure
there is an artificial deficit of
disagreement over what is to happen next
and a
you know a false consensus about do more
do it now and here's the stuff you know
defund abolish
all of these things although um i think
it was the first action of the city
council after the recent election
um which had an important vote that went
a different way because mingus maps won
this this seat from incumbent uh chloe
utili
voted against uh city council member
hardesty's desire to
defund by 18 million dollars the
portland police bureau
um so that that it seemed like that was
going to go through which would have
been i wish i knew what fraction the
the police budget that was and i don't
remember it seemed like that was going
to go through and that would have been a
devastating blow
to police and policing in portland but
it did not go through so you know again
there are these
little things the election happened uh
we got
an apparent rejection of the chaos on
the streets of portland
and yet still as of two three nights ago
there is still black block marauding on
the streets doing you know vandalism
and and why like why
who who wants to live in a society like
that
yeah it's uh nobody it's not a society
um and you know
one hopeful note i did talk to somebody
this week who i'm going to interview
on the podcast um who has been close in
with these circles
and it sounds like the
that you know we've argued that there
are two forces that came together
this summer that you had a black lives
matter force motivated by
george floyd's death and you had a
long-standing arc
why did i just lose the word anarchist
thread here in the pacific northwest and
that these things became one
well and you had cove at exhaustion well
you had lots of contributing factors you
had two factions okay yes
marched together and were involved in
some kind of dynamic that was big
and they seem to be going their separate
ways and
to the extent that what is going on in
portland and in some other
major cities is actually about anarchism
maybe the public is going to start to
wake up that just because they save
black lives matter before
they bust in your storefront is you know
doesn't make this a coherent action that
yeah these people if you talk to them
they really do have this nonsense idea
that the
the route to the better world is just to
tear it all down
and that we will be better off without
it and you know
they're nuts and frankly i think it's a
lot easier to recognize the insanity of
their position than it is to understand
what's wrong with black lives matter
because of course
you know the black lives matter's slogan
uh is right right and so it covers a lot
but just to put the the final thing on
the
the part about the levels of analysis we
see an analogous structure when we talk
about
uh something like vaccine safety
right we see a public health level
analysis
that we are then told that we must
adhere to at the point we talk about
individual safety now there's a reason
for that
right there's actually a hazard in
people doing the individual calculation
rather than the group calculation
but nonetheless it doesn't make it true
right so we have not figured out how to
deal with that and it's the same
you know uh individual versus population
level analysis
flaw where what we effectively have is a
collective action problem
i think this is actually one of the
biggest failures of education that we
have with regard you know
there are plenty of failures of
education in terms of how it's done
about which we have a lot to say and
have
written a lot in the book that will be
coming out next year
but in terms of what are things missing
from the minds of people who have
supposedly been educated
is this the distinction between
individual and population and i think i
may have even said it in the
live stream before but um you will be
familiar with with my story of in
2006 i was teaching with uh this
terrific entomologist jack longinos a
friend of ours
um a freshman level program so we had 50
18 year olds mostly
a freshman program did tend to have a
college age typical students
and we took them into you know the scalp
lands in eastern washington in week two
and and
it was i think it was called
understanding species and so we were
talking about species from you know
genetics all the way up to sort of
landscape level you know we went through
all these different levels of
understanding scale at in biology
and we also did statistics workshops uh
and i asked him
in advance you know what is the thing
that you want
uh that you think the students are most
most in need of understanding at the end
of this
and he said exactly this and this is the
first time i'd heard it framed this way
but they need to understand the
distinction between what it is to be an
individual
and what it is to be a population and
that statistics deal with populations
and that they don't have as much to say
about what individuals are
or are capable of and you know that last
bit is my editorializing but i think i
know that man's mind well enough to know
that he would have thought that too
and it is is both critical
and extraordinarily hard sometimes to
get people to pull back whenever you
make a claim
that unless you're constantly signaling
i'm now talking at population level
everyone assumes that it's always about
the individual
yes and this is ironically a bias of the
mind built by evolution because you can
very rarely do anything about the
population level analysis
um and so we're obsessed with individual
self stuff because it's where
our power is not because it's what's
important um
you know so we also see this in the
analysis inside of evolutionary theory
this is why i argue
we have failed to understand lineage
selection we have a skew and our
our understanding to individual level
selection difficult to operationalize
right um but yeah i would say the pair
with the idea of individual versus
population is
collective action problem right how many
of our societal problems
simply come down to this which is if the
individuals have the ability
to negate the policy that
correctly mirrors our collective
interests
they will very frequently do so and so
you know we get into very
deep territory very quickly right you've
got tragedy of the commons and then
you've got eleanor ostrom's
wonderful work describing how um
populations
with long-standing tragedies of the
commons have solved them and what the
necessary characteristics are
and frankly you know it's worth a year
right if you took a year to study these
topics and you just focused on them
exclusively right you would come out so
much wiser
about how it is that we are to to
manage the future um but
no dice it's very hard to sell people on
that idea well and i think um
just speaking for me anecdotally you
know i actually i
i've got ostrom's book now on my
nightstand and i have yet to crack it up
and i've been working on some other
stuff but
um it doesn't draw me right like i know
it's important and i very much want to
to read her stuff and to internalize it
and
um i find it i find it hard to access
and it's not that i can't do it but the
motivation
you know if i've got five books before
me that so far it hasn't been the one
that i have chosen um so that we do we
do also need to do something
to either change the motivation or offer
this sort of material in a different way
you know at least at this point it can't
be us like i just don't i don't know it
enough you know i basically know your
sound the sound bites that you have
provided here and you know a little bit
more but not
not a tremendous amount more well um
interestingly
there's this little debate that has
threatened to break out
between me and david sloan wilson in
fact we've twice scheduled it and uh
it's gonna happen it has to happen um
between his
group selection and multi-level
selection and my lineage selection
um and the interesting thing is i will
argue
a lot of the stuff downstream of that
conversation we agree on
right and we are in disagreement with
most of the field and i think frankly
we're both right about the importance of
what's downstream
including you are both in disagreement
with most of the field we are in
agreement with each other and we are
both in disagreement with the majority
of the field
and frankly the you know the field has
to catch up to the meaning of cultural
evolution which you can't see because
it's so focused on
individual level selection and genes and
genes of course
um but in any case the
uh you know a pillar of what's
downstream
is this awesome work and to the extent
that i think you're right i think
you know people who get into it and are
aware of the questions in this
neighborhood
find it profound and important but it's
not
it's not uh super accessible so
maybe there's something that needs to be
done to you know just as with
tragedy of the commons and other
collective action problems
there's something that needs to be done
to make it clear why this is so
important
it's like it's an unsolvable problem or
it's a solved problem
and you know either you see what
solutions look like and you figure well
how do we import that into this system
uh or you don't and then you're
constantly fighting why are people doing
dumb fit
and they're doing dumb [ __ ] because of
conflicts between levels of analysis
yeah speaking of which jordan peterson
announced his new book
uh this week on his youtube channel and
right on cue
a number of employees of the publishing
house i believe it's penguin canada
uh where his book is being published uh
went i don't know it's like the opposite
of ballistic went weepy
and uh and woke and complained
probably that they're safe that they
were endangered by
having such a you know alt-right
transphobe which of course he's not
um be published at the same in the same
place that he that
that they work as if they even have to
read the book or
interact with him in any way so right or
as if publishing
books with bad stuff in it is somehow
not done
now you know right right if they viewed
it as bad then
uh it's still not an argument against
publishing it yeah
so i don't know if we want to say
anything more about that um
but it's we wanted to walk through a few
examples
of um the kind of bad thinking and bad
um you know at some level collective
actions um that are taking place right
now
and the presumably decision
by at least some small cabal of
employees at
penguin canada to resist to object to
this book
is a perfect example of you know bad
thinking and you know wow
how did you end up in publishing how do
you end up presumably
caring about literature and books uh if
the idea of a book being published in
the same
under the same name as you draw your
paychecks from
is causing such distress to you it seems
like it seems like you may be in the
wrong field
in the wrong field indeed i will say i
did find something
distressing when i read this news for
the first time
in which news that the news of the
publication by
penguin canada because i regard penguin
canada
as a woeful geographic misinterpretation
of phylogeny and i don't know if it was
puffins or
what that had been misidentified but
frankly
um it's a non-sequitur yeah you
okay there are no penguins in canada not
remotely
right but they didn't think so no they
didn't no no
um and then just another example of you
know this is
a couple months old now but it's still
it's active at the moment is university
of chicago's english department
um has uh outlined
let's see um let's go to their website
here zach this is the department of
english at the university of chicago one
of the
top universities in the country and they
make all sorts of claims about how
awesome their department is
which i would imagine are true once
famous for the aristotelians chicago
school of criticism of the 1950s today
the department ranked
first among english departments in the
u.s stands out for its interdisciplinary
approach
to literature and its commitment to
close reading combined with historical
and conceptual analysis well that sounds
awesome doesn't it we certainly need
english we need intact amazing
deep diving deep hard driving humanities
we absolutely do
i i began my college career as you know
in an english department i was a
literature major for two years before i
ran away because
it was making no sense and that was in
the late 80s early 90s
so let us go down however to the faculty
statement which was released in july of
2020.
um the second paragraph reads
for the 2020-2021 graduate admission
cycle
the university of chicago english
department is accepting only applicants
interested in working in and with black
studies
we understand black studies to be a
capacious intellectual project
that spans a variety of methodological
approaches fields geographical areas
languages and time periods
so yeah i'm sure you're headed here but
go
go for it well i first of all want to
point out that this isn't just
a spectacular
miscarriage of academic integrity
but it is happening in a most
unfortunate place because this is the
university of chicago
and the university of chicago was like
the one
example of a school doing its best to
stand its ground
against the uh the nonsense
emerging from the illiberal left
yeah and so the chicago principles
um are famously a statement
of a refusal to kowtow to this and
uh to have their english department
deciding that the only people they are
interested in talking to are people
who are studying uh
what was their term black studies oh
yeah it's black studies
black studies is um an indication
that you know well i mean this has been
the message all along if there were
a disagreement you know if 60 of
american universities were falling prey
to this and 40 percent were not
we'd be in a very different situation if
it was even 10 that we're not we'd be in
a very different situation because
those schools that resisted would have
an advantage if we are right
that this is nonsense thinking then they
would have an advantage and over time
the system would self-correct but the
very fact that it's no schools that are
successfully
resisting this tells you the nature of
it right
it is authoritarian in nature and very
powerful because if it weren't
it couldn't be dictating terms to all of
these schools in which frankly there
are you know thousands of people who
know better
yeah now and so for those of you who
aren't familiar um zach you can just put
up very briefly this is the chicago
principles
um the actual statement at
provost.uchicago.edu
uh which is short but i won't read the
whole thing here um
from its very founding it begins the
university of chicago has dedicated
itself to the preservation and
celebration of the freedom of expression
as an essential element of the
university's culture
in 1902 in his address mark in the
university's decennial
presidential president william rainey
harper declared that quote
the principle of complete freedom of
speech on all subjects has from the
beginning been regarded as fundamental
in the university of chicago and that
quote
this principle can neither now nor any
future time be called in question
so at the point the campuses were
beginning to um become
unhinged in i don't know 2015
2016 um the chicago principles
uh came as this just like beacon of
light
and it seemed clear that many many
universities should follow should adopt
them
and a few did formally adopt chicago
principles
um but no one is standing up to say
actually this
this here goes down exactly that road
this this what the department of english
is doing
at the university of chicago in terms of
limiting
not just not actually not who can get in
but what you must be interested in in
order to get into their phd program for
the fall of 2021 um is a step down the
road
um to lack of freedom of expression it
absolutely
is it it really is and um i was
listening
i haven't listened to the whole thing
but someone pointed us
to a very recent interview with glenn
greenwald
on the reason podcast in which
he says very much like what matt taibi
has said
that he initially dismissed what
happened on college campuses
because so much happens on college
campuses and people grow out of it
right and basically he said i think this
is a quote he said it turned out the
people who were concerned were right
um because this ideology was
taken into the world from these colleges
and it is now affecting editorial boards
etcetera
that's not all a quote that's me
paraphrasing but um
but in any case um this is very
important
and it remains important because it's
not like the people who learned this on
college campuses took it into the world
it's until we stop it from being
the gospel that is being dispensed on
college campuses
it will continue to be taken into the
world and the point is
you know it's like climate change right
you you know
if you fixed things today you would
still have a problem for
for some time because of the delay in
the process and so
if we want to get this right we have to
get the college part of it right
instantly and we're just we're heading
the wrong direction yes we are
and um yeah yes yes we are
maybe maybe maybe that so um in
partial response to all of this this
madness
um i wanted to read a passage from milan
kundra
which is you know i find it both hopeful
and sad
this this passage for those who wear
black block
and vandalized supermarkets and statues
they pulled out another statue in a
cemetery as well
in portland a few nights ago and for
those who declare their lack of safety
yet another book of jordan peterson's
being published
and for those academic departments that
would like to limit the kinds of
questions that are asked
in some really misguided attempt
to write the wrongs of history this
would also be useful
i would say um to illuminate
um for for instance new york times op-ed
columnists
uh what kinds of things can happen if
you go down this road so
for those who don't know kundra is a is
a czech writer i actually had
i thought that he was gone but he's not
he's 91 years old now born 1929.
uh he went into exile in france in 1975
and considers himself now a french
writer i think of him as a czech
dissident
but um before the velvet revolution in
czechoslovakia which was in
1989 uh which overthrew the communist
party which had been in power for many
decades
um the communist regime banned his books
so he uh is a he was
and remains a long-standing criticism of
things like totalitarianism and
communism where it
where it shows up including in his home
country
his czechoslovak citizenship was revoked
in 1979 but he was given check
citizenship in 2019
something i learned in reviewing wow
um and i received an email
a month ago from a viewer of the podcast
uh who pointed me to a short excerpt
from
from this book which i can you see the
book of laughter and forgetting
um which i have a copy because as i have
mentioned on this podcast before i read
a bunch of kundera and sultanates in my
very first quarter in college when i was
when i was a literature major
and um before i read this excerpt this
short excerpt
i will say there's an historical note
for a couple of people who are mentioned
uh in here and so this again from the
person who wrote to me
the framing kundera mentions both
gotwald and clementis and i'm not sure
i'm pronouncing that right
gotwald was the president of
czechoslovakia from 48 to 53
and he allowed stalin to gut the
communist party of czechoslovakia
of most if not all the semi-independent
and well-intentioned intellectuals
clementis um who famously had given
his fur hat to gotwald on a freezing day
in prague and there's a photograph of
got wild ware and clementi's for a hat
um was later seen as an enemy of the
state and was cropped out of images so
he's this is one of these famous
um stories of someone literally being
cropped out of images
so that you only see gotwald and
clementus has been literally erased
from photographic history so those are
gottwald and clementis from this um
and oh so i have this this book that
i've had since
i don't know i guess 1987. um but i
actually found that the
the translation that was sent to me is
one i like better so i'm going to read
this one
since there is not a this is so this is
again sorry from uh the book of laughter
and forgetting which was written in 1979
um when the czechoslovakian communist
party was still in power
before the revolution 10 years later
since there is not a single historic
event we can count on being commonly
known
i must speak of events that took place a
few years ago as if they were a thousand
years old
in 1939 the german army entered bohemia
and the czech state
ceased to exist in 1945 the russian army
entered bohemia and the country once
again was called an independent republic
the people were enthusiastic about the
russia that had driven out the germans
and seeing in the czech communist party
its faithful arm they became sympathetic
to
it so the communists took power in
february 1949 with neither bloodshed nor
violence
but greeted by the cheers of about half
the nation and now please note
the half that did the cheering was the
more dynamic the more intelligent the
better
yes say what you will the communists
were more intelligent they had an
imposing program
a plan for an entirely new world where
everyone would find a place
the opponents had no great dream only
some tiresome and threadbare moral
principles with which they tried to
patch the torn trousers of the
established order
so it's no surprise that the enthusiasts
the spirited ones easily won out over
the half-heartedly cautious
and rapidly set out to realize their
dream that idol of justice for all
i emphasize idol and for all because all
human beings have always aspired to an
idol to that garden where nightingales
sing
to that realm of harmony where the world
does not rise up as a stranger against
man a man against other men but rather
where the world and all men
are shaped from one and the same matter
everyone is a note in a sublime bach
fugue and anyone who refuses to be one
is a mere useless and meaningless black
dot that need only be cotton crush
between thumb and finger like a flea
there were people who immediately
understood that they did not have the
right temperament for the idol and tried
to go abroad
but since the idol is in essence a world
for all those who tried to emigrate
showed themselves to be deniers of the
idol
and instead of going abroad they went
behind bars
thousands and tens of thousands of
others soon joined them including many
communists like the foreign minister
clementis
who had lent his fur hat to gottwald
timid lovers held hands on the movie
screens adultery was harshly suppressed
by citizens tribunals of honor
nightingale saying and the body of
clementis swung like a bell ringing in
the new dawn of humanity
and then those young intelligent and
radical people suddenly had the strange
feeling of having sent out into the
world an
act that had begun to lead a life of its
own had ceased to resemble the idea it
was based on it did not care about those
who had created it
those young and intelligent people
started to scold their act they began to
call to it
to rebuke it to pursue it to give chase
to it
if i were to write a novel about that
gifted and radical generation
i would call it in pursuit of an errant
act
yeah um so my goodness
uh struck by many things there maybe
top of the list is his point about
the fact that the communists were
smarter
and i would point out that this is not
uncommon
that there is something very appealing
about a
marxist analysis to smart people and
it's in part because there's some truth
in it
great deal of truth but the problem is
it misses the collective action problem
issue this is exactly why it falters and
it is exactly why
it necessarily leads to totalitarianism
because the fact that you cannot get
there
through people's individual alignment of
interests causing
the collective well-being phenomenon to
function
the fact that that is unstable because
people's individual interest functions
against the collective interests
that thing forces you to punish people
into compliance and yeah um and he's
arguing not only that they're smarter
but they're more charismatic
he's he speaks to the appeal of the
movement as well that the people who
in in the case of the of what happened
in in
the czech republic or czechoslovakia in
the mid 20th century
uh the people who were defending who
were against the communist revolution
were defending a status quo and there
was no passion there there was no
interesting narrative they didn't have
any interesting way forward they were
just defending what had been
and this is how much of the modern stuff
is framed too that anyone
who is denying this movement must be
backward looking regressive
conservative all of these things and um
frankly this is i think often that is
simply dishonest
dishonest framing but it but it does
reveal
that they they they've got the messaging
right they've got the charisma
right that we can simultaneously
recognize the traditions
and the founding principles on which we
stand are necessary and that we can do
better
and that we can move forward with new
ideas
and be better than we have been and that
does not require and
actually absolutely mandates that we not
destroy all that has come before it also
i think reflects
a tendency um a
very bad habit that virtually all of us
have to some degree
or another which is to pay closest
attention to the top of something and
pay less and less attention as you move
down
right so the read the abstract version
and then
barely skim the paper if at all
phenomenon that we see in academia
has a more general analog and
you know so the thing about marxism the
part that does have
real merit has to do with the analysis
of what happens under other
circumstances and the problem is
that the prescriptive part is completely
wrong why is it completely wrong
well not least because of this
collective action issue
right and so the idea that people that
smart people are suckered
by the you know the first paragraph that
sounds
like something that they've seen and
then what they misunderstand is that if
you apply the remedy that's proposed you
know it's snake oil at some level
yeah no it is and um
unnuanced respondents will say what do
you not think that socioeconomic class
divisions
are driving a lot of the problems in
society today and at any other moment
when
a communist revolution has been proposed
to which many of us can say no
absolutely
but but your solution is wrong and it
will make things worse
but your solution is wrong and the
degree to which you think that this is a
problem is also wrong
so i i've uh you know
the older i get the more i realize that
there is some sort of
fundamental difference between those of
us who think
that absolute economic equality is a
desirable objective
and those of us who believe that
actually it isn't and that although we
would like a safety net that protects
people
from falling below an honorable standard
of living
right that the you know you
want people who bring great things to
the world
because they are determined to do it and
invest mightily in order to get there
you want those people
to have some upgrade to their quality of
life and you want people
who decide that they're not really
interested in doing anything for planet
earth
you want those people to live less well
doesn't mean anybody should be homeless
it doesn't mean anybody
should you know lack health care but the
fact is
you know some equalization is probably
desirable um you know a
a floor to well-being is surely a
desirable state of being but
um those who would pursue equality to
the point of absurdity and i mean
economic equality obviously
other kinds of equality
we should strive for them but economic
equality is not
in and of itself a good greater equality
is from where we are because the
inequality is so great but
equality itself is not the objective
well i guess
also there may be a problem with the
words right like we know that equality
and equity are not the same things
and equality in general refers to
equality
equality of opportunity and equity in
general referring to
equality of outcome or identity of
outcome
but then we can also speak to for
instance equality under the law
of men and women right and um
under the law is the important thing
there and it says nothing about what we
expect
outcomes to be with regard to relative
representation
in particular uh fields in particular
professions
right or um or
death rates from particular diseases you
know you're not
you can't democratize um the selective
forces that have been acting differently
on men and women for hundreds of
millions of years not men and women but
males and females for hundreds of
millions of years you're not going to be
able to do it
and um imagine you know putting that as
your goal means that
you know you win if part of your point
is you always want to be in struggle
you always want to have a cause and what
you are primarily is an activist
who must go onto the streets and
proclaim that things must change
but if you're actually interested in a
better world in which
there is a there could be a moment if
you cannot imagine a moment
when you would be satisfied enough to to
leave the streets
then um it's not good faith protest and
you have no business getting any of our
attention
yeah absolutely absolutely um
i had a thought i lost it but uh in any
case
all right well should we go on should we
talk a little bit about um christopher
hitchens
yeah these quotes that you found uh
actually they were sent to me by a
mutual friend
of ours um and i think i want to set
this up because hitches is sort of the
punch line to it
and the point is that you and i
encountered
something i will speak with a bit
obliquely for the moment
we encountered an analysis of where we
are with respect to covid that is
very challenging and the
i was struck by the fact that apparently
this analysis would pull was pulled down
from youtube within two hours of being
put up
now i expected um something
like what we ran into with pandemic and
uh judy mikovich where you and i
separately watched that video and alarm
bells were regularly ringing about the
analysis there were things about it that
were clearly
wrong um there were also there was also
that video put out by the kern county
doctors
um early on which is different from
landemic but similarly when we did
we we did an analysis of it it just
nothing
didn't stand up nothing worked right now
in either case would
i and i assume you advocate that these
things shouldn't be
viewable right um both of those were
also pulled down
and they should then they shouldn't have
been right right um but this
analysis that we've uh most recently
seen is
very very challenging and i have to say
i think the assumption has to be that
there is something seriously wrong with
it but the person advancing
the analysis is very well credentialed
which
is also uh arguably the case in judy
mikovich's
case and the current county doctors also
had a clinical
background so anyway you know these were
not uh
kooks with no position from which to
speak but in this case we've got
somebody who's really well
positioned and he makes a very
interesting
argument which i will say i now think i
know how to test but
um but here's the problem
it was pulled down from youtube in two
hours
it is now viewable on a blockchain-based
video site that effectively protects it
from uh
you know from interference of you know
below a certain level lbry
excited i don't think so but i'm not
sure
um in any case here's the problem we
have a youtube channel
that youtube channel is subject to
guidelines
that are impenetrable and unfollowable
to discuss this question um
for us to talk about for us to talk
about it leaves open the possibility
that google will decide we are over some
line some line that
we would obviously argue and most
certainly win the argument that the line
is nowhere near this that this is a
discussable hypothetical deductive
question that there are
proper tools to be brought to bear on it
but the fact is
there is no the guidelines themselves
are vague the there is no the community
guidelines of google
right there is no court in which you can
uh
plead your case the fact that the video
was pulled down in the first place says
that google has
taken up the opinion that discussion of
this
because the presentation itself is
responsible
right it makes arguments that are
evaluable it suggests that google
uh takes a view that i would argue is
indefensible but there's nowhere to make
that argument
it suggests just like we were talking
about at the beginning of the hour
that there is this vision of what
science
is in blue team's heads that
once we have an answer that we've agreed
on that is the truth
and no further evidence can possibly
take that truth off its pedestal because
that
is has always been will always be true
and that of course is not at all how
science works
so what we want to do what we have been
doing is speak to the uncertainty
and and weigh evidence and talk about
what it would mean if
but in this case it would be really
really dangerous to us
it would it would be dangerous and
um there is no mechanism to figure out
ahead of time what comes of it right or
you know what line you know google can
be wrong about
what the line is but it could be
specific about it so that we could say
the line doesn't belong here
but in the interest of uh continuing to
be able to talk about these things we'll
stay on the side of it but we there is
no line is the problem the line
is a judgment call to some uh
unaccountable
mechanism so here's the here's the
predicament
you and i were driven out of very secure
jobs by nonsense we are fortunate that
the tools
with which to architect a different
livelihood exists in the world right
we were able to you know we didn't have
to build a server
farm to serve videos to every corner of
the
world that thing simply exists you can
sign up you know build your channel the
tools you know to sell merchandise or
whatever all of these things are just
available there and that's a marvelous
thing to exist but the problem is
they are all subject to the veto of an
unaccountable authority
that delivers guidelines that you cannot
adhere to the only way to be anywhere
close to certain that your livelihood
will continue into next week
is to say so far basically to do the
bidding of those
who would control speech right you have
to stay away from anything
that could be understood you know and
maybe this is another
place to point it out the reason that
something like google
might decide that we can't have a
discussion about the validity
or lack of validity of this expert's
point about
current covit and its apparent
resurgence
that has again to do with the difference
in analysis between
the individual and the collective in
effect what google is doing
is they are deciding that a discussion
of this will cause individuals to make
decisions
that are not in our collective interest
and so google has decided for us that
the way
to address that problem is to inflict a
conclusion
as if it is absolutely secure so that
the
actual analysis does not occur in public
so that nobody will draw what they
consider to be the foregone wrong
conclusion
right so all of that is google deciding
what the answer to the question is and
therefore what
people are to do in light of it and this
is completely intolerable
heterodoxy does deal with all of these
ambiguities
it does deal with the difference in
level of analysis between the individual
level and the collective level
and there's a lot to be said about it
but what you know the world we are
living in is one where we are free to
make a living using tools provided by
google but we dare not disagree with it
about whether or not
this can be discussed in public right
and this is
absolutely preposterous and it raises
all sorts of questions as
your kundera passage does
now what does that have to do with
hitchens um
so the point is as i was describing this
to
a friend he pointed me to a couple of
quotes that come from christopher
hitchens actually will you put the first
one up zach
yep it's november
i just thought i'd mentioned it was
november while zach is uh returning to
the job at hand and bringing up the
relevant quote yeah
still november
yep christopher hitchens i have a word
okay
okay oh boy all right it says the true
essence of a dictatorship
is in fact not in its regularity but in
its unpredictability and caprice
those who live under it must never be
able to relax must never be quite
sure if they have followed the rules
correctly
or not and that's christopher hitchens
from the book hitch 22
you want to scroll down here's the other
quote
the essential principle of
totalitarianism is to make laws that are
impossible to obey christopher hitchens
from god is not great
so um i have a principle from long ago
which i call the low posted speed limit
yes yes you do um and the low posted
speed limit is a speed limit posted so
low that a reasonable driver will almost
certainly violate it and what this
allows you to do
is punish those you like so you you the
state you're the state if
if you're you know a cop in a town with
a speed limit so low that everybody
violates it then you can pull over gays
or jews or long hairs or
whoever you don't like right and the
point is
the law does not read as if it is biased
against
the law is not bigoted right but it
allows for bigotry to flourish
exactly and so the arbitrariness and the
caprice
of the um of the
structure the fact that the standard is
set so low that enforcement is perfectly
arbitrary or can be
allows all kinds of things to happen and
the fact that hitchens connects this to
totalitarianism that he
argues that this is in fact a feature
and not a bug
that in order to make totalitarianism
work you have to constantly be looking
over your shoulder
with the fear that you have violated the
rule even if that wasn't your intent
because that thing can come back to
haunt you and uh
in in a dire manner that is what keeps
the thing
uh humming and to be to find that we are
facing this in our relationship
with these platforms that are frankly
giving us all of these marvelous tools
with which we might otherwise be
you know upgrading our collective
understanding of things
but instead they're going to manage our
collective understanding uh
in ways that prevent people who do have
relevant expertise from
sharing it discussing its possible
implications falsifying it in public
right is uh is is absolutely disastrous
so it really is a third thing that
you've just said so your low p
your low posted speed limit principle
uh which is that you make a law which
almost everyone breaks
such that the enforcement of that law
allows
individuals who are tasked with
enforcing
to enact their internal bigotry or
whatever it is that's one thing that's
what you have said
um hitchens says um you make laws that
are impossible to obey which is
different from low posted speed limit
low posted speed limit is you tend not
to obey them
um but you could yeah um he says
totalitarianism is the creation of laws
that are impossible to obey and then his
third one the one we started with
um is the unpredictability and caprice
of the rules such that you never know
this is where we started with regard to
can we talk about some of this possible
new covet discussion that's coming out
we don't know google google has not told
us the community guidelines are vague
presumably intentionally and this gets
to hitchen's point
right that um it is the unpredictability
and caprice
and um effectively that is
it's certainly related to your low
posted speed limit but i think it's
distinct i think these really are three
distinct
things all of which which we're seeing
in play
with things like the tech giants at the
moment who have
such remarkable control over not just
those of us who are creating and
producing content
um but you know all of us who are also
um consuming content and having are
having the options before us changed by
hidden forces
uh that we cannot see nor into it um
and i would say you either cannot figure
out whether
something is uh is against the rules or
you can but only
putting your livelihood in jeopardy
which is not
unlike what totalitarian regimes do you
know you do something and you may find
yourself behind bars
you know and in this case i do want to
emphasize though there is something
uh hauntingly familiar from
these totalitarian regimes there's also
brand new stuff here and
one of my concerns is that because and i
actually did a little checking
because none of the phenomena which
carry the hallmarks
of totalitarianism or fascism
check all of the boxes right we are
going to persistently be
in this state where we see hints of
these things but we never cross the
final threshold there
because in fact the list of
characteristics that we
have been led to expect are based on a
historical
world that we no longer live in and so
you know we're not going to face fascism
again
of the same kind but we're going to face
something with those tendencies and very
different tools
and you know the worst thing here
is that one of the tools in a world of
platforms
using algorithms to enforce arbitrary
standards there is a tendency
both naturally because it's simple and
arbitrarily and politically because
it's expedient for each side to do it
there's a tendency
to say this is our team here's what we
believe
anything outside of that zone is the
enemy and is to be dealt with
as such which means that the the surface
of that bubble now cannot be penetrated
with new information
or you know the stuff of upgrade right
it can't be because everything else is
viewed
as hostile and wrong and so i think you
and i
are continually tripping over this right
and
the stuff around unity being suspended
at twitter and the stuff about me being
tossed off of facebook
has to do with the fact that these
goddamn algorithms don't know what to do
with heterodoxy because in general what
they encounter
is people who show themselves to be on
one team or another
and if your litmus test for that is
doesn't believe these
things then lots of us don't believe
these things but we also don't believe
those things and so the point is
you know your your algorithm's no good
here right
yeah the there it is heterodoxy renders
the algorithm incapable of figuring out
what you are
right you know you're a platypus in a
world where you've got
you know birds with bills and you know
mammals with fur
right and you know how much
harm are we doing to our collective
sense making
by virtue of stupid algorithms that are
looking to put us in too few categories
to deal with those of us
who frankly might have something
important to add to the conversation
but it's going to be you know
neutralized out of existence
yeah so we have talked um and your
brother has talked about
trying to be ash negative right to not
be the person who conforms to patently
false things that are being said in your
presence
be the kind of person for whom the
algorithms
of big tech and everyone else are no
good here
be able to say your algorithm is no good
here and figure out ways
to obscure yourself from it to hide from
it to evade it to move forward without
it seeing you
and i don't know what all of those ways
are at all but
um heterodox thinking is the way forward
not accepting an ideology that has been
handed to you
by blue or by red or by the left or
right or whoever it is
that if you've accepted an ideology
because you agree with one thing in it
and assume that therefore everything
else is true you are not an independent
thinker and you are very likely to get
conned
yeah you are very likely to get conned
is is right um
i i will say i'm struck i know
some people weren't all that into us
discussing clubhouse but
uh this platform this new platform that
is
still in beta but is growing in terms of
its population
is revealing to those of us who are
paying attention to it
why this is so difficult because inside
of this platform and again the platform
is uh all spoken word
real time it's synchronous you get into
a room and you have a discussion with
people
many of whom you don't know but
there is a feature in which you can
block people
of course like every other platform but
those blocks have an
impact if somebody
who is in a position i think somebody is
a moderator in a room
where they've blocked you you can't see
that the room exists at all which means
that from the point of view of the
people in the room
there is a tendency for the conversation
to actually conform to a standard so to
the extent
that you know i might be disliked by
people who are
advancing the the blm banner
they may block me it means i can't see
the conversations they're having
i won't be present in those
conversations and they will have an
artificially narrow view
of the range of thought on this issue
because people who are heterodox
won't be there to speak and so you know
it's a damned if you do damned if you
don't problem they're trying to solve
one problem and creating what i think is
a much bigger problem
in so doing but you can just see that
people
i don't know the solution to that one
though i don't i don't think you can i
don't know anything about this platform
ever been on it but i don't think you
can have a social media platform that
doesn't allow you to block
well you could allow people to
individually block
and then there's no way to stop such i'm
sorry i missed something about the
you individually block but then the the
platform
infers from your block that you are not
welcome in certain spaces so you can't
even see that they exist
so instead of so it infers something
that in some case you know if you've got
a troll there who's just making trouble
sure right you can imagine that you
don't want such a person to show up in
that room but
by doing that you are creating power for
those who would block
and in fact this is an analog for
the system that the other platforms have
established in which
they claim oh an algorithm flagged you
sorry right
why did the algorithm flag me oh because
a bunch of people reported you
why did they report you oh because they
viewed you as on the other side they
were doing a political job by reporting
you which then triggered the algorithm
which then allowed
the platform to decide what it thought
of you and it used the algorithm as an
excuse
yeah so your algorithm is no good here
yeah it's more of that let's create more
of that yeah
um i think we are way past an hour at
this point
um so i'm going to advocate that we move
big game hunting in the americas by
women to next week
make sure we talk about that at the top
of the hour but i want to say just a
couple of minutes before we
before we break before going to super
chat questions about
um about the value of going outside
specifically again it's something that
i've said at the end of some of these
live streams get outside
for those of you in the northern
hemisphere as most of you are it's
increasingly
um unpleasant unless you happen to be
you know
if you were in that shoulder season as
we are on the pacific northwest
um at low altitudes it pretty much
consistently is
if it's you know in the 40s and cold and
wet it's about as difficult to motivate
to go out as
as it gets but i was i was thinking the
last time actually that i was out on my
stand-up pedalboard
which as long time viewers will know i
started doing just in august of this
year and quickly fell in love with it
and i was out on it uh in the
penultimate week of october
when it was already was pretty pretty
cold that day pretty windy
and i was just
so filled with love for it being out
there
and it reminded me of how i have never
been able to get into being in a gym
i've now i've never had a gym membership
i've never spent time in a public gym
um and you know and why like what what
is it specifically
about that kind of exercise that cannot
motivate me in any way
and the thing that i came up with while
i'm standing out up out there and the
willamette um
uh on with you know white caps on the
river uh
was that there's no stakes there's no
stakes in the gym
and you know i i know so little about
this and i'm sure i'll get pushback here
you know that's there are some things
that you need a spotter for
and um that you need to make sure that
you don't um you know
drop things um if you if you don't have
a spotter you know on parts of you um
but really it's so controlled and so
uniform and so homogeneous from
from one visit to the next and indeed
that's part of the point for people that
we have this focus on quantification and
metrics and allows us to
imagine that we're tracking progress and
therefore that we're making progress
um but the stakes it seems to me are
almost entirely social you know did i
embarrass myself
in front of the the cute guy or girl
over there you know was
did i you know do do i look ridiculous
or am i you know am i showing myself in
my best form
and um as we have said before
many times seeking out those things that
reveal physical reality and not social
reality
are a better way to actually know
whether or not you're making sense in
the world
and of course if you know you can or
cannot lift x amount of weight
um if you can or cannot bench press x
amount of weight this time and you
and you couldn't a month ago that does
tell you something real
but you're not at any risk really
right and um
anything outside really even walking
certainly biking skiing stand-up
paddleboarding but even
walking um the weather might come
right um there might be rocks or
slipperiness
or you know any number of things that
just increases the chances that there
might be
some damage that is unrelated to the you
know physical activity that it would use
to describe it
and it's it's related i think to this
idea of having skin in the game
uh which is an idea that's older than
teles formulation but
um naseem to leb talks about this a lot
but it's not a perfect overlap with skin
in the game but it's
it's related so you can you you i would
say
that we are all going to be more
inspired um to
to be our best selves both in terms of
our mental acuity and also our physical
selves if we can figure out at least
sometimes ways to go
and move our bodies um in active ways
outside where there's actual challenges
that we cannot completely foresee
as opposed to entirely in fully
controlled environments so i would add
one thing to it i agree that there's
something to just the reality
of an environment with stakes even if
you're attempting to be
safe at it there's something to the
variation
in the outside environment the variation
which is specifically purged from
the gym yeah so a couple places it shows
up
i've been trying to keep at biking as
the weather has become less and less
pleasant for it and the app that i
use to just keep track of where i've
gone um
allows you to store a picture with each
trip
and trying to figure out you know
especially when i'm going the same place
very frequently the question is okay
well what picture will i take
somewhere along my ride i need to get a
picture that is unique to this ride
right that doesn't just look like the
same vista or whatever it might be
and that is a a mental puzzle worth
engaging
right likewise the difference in
weather between one ride and the next
and frankly the
always surprisingly difficult puzzle of
feeling figuring out how to dress
for the you know the fall
winter spring months that puzzle
is thought-provoking right and
especially because it does have
consequences right
you dress incorrectly and you're either
overheating because you haven't figured
out a way to shed enough heat
or you know you're losing heat faster
than you can generate it and
you know even the how you remain in the
zone
between building up heat faster than you
can lose it and losing heat faster than
you can build it
right that's an interesting physical
puzzle yeah right and
so anyway something anything that causes
you to engage in the world to think
about
the moon phase the number of hours of
daylight which is frankly it will
surprise many of you
um we are about to go in
we are still in the ebbing direction but
we are about to turn the corner and go
in the direction of
longer days for those of you in the
northern hemisphere although the day
length is
shortening rather slowly now and will
increase rather slowly through
you know mid-february or no late january
at which point it begins to speed up
again
even as temperature continues to drop
right um
which is an interesting puzzle for
people to think about but anything that
provokes you
this is right watching the you know the
change
in the biota you know in the different
seasons
uh the different sounds even the
different sounds of the city and the way
that they
reverberate differently you know with
different weather patterns
different leaves on the trees different
cloud cover all of it yeah
um and i guess i feel like i would be
remiss
if i said all of that and didn't and i
think i'd like to just asterisk this
here and maybe come back to it but
um we have a friend edith hoist who's
got
a a program of indoor exercises
called revolution in motion and
revolutionarmotion.com will get you
there
um that that are extraordinary
and the a big part of the point of
it is it it brings in instability
and puts you in different planes
relative to your usual gravitational
plane of reference
as you are bearing weight and moving on
things like a big exercise ball and on
inclined planes and on slopes and such
and
um it you know and this is she she is
extraordinary and she also goes out you
know she kayaks and stand up pedal
boards and bikes and all these things
and um this is sort of a way of engaging
your
your core self and the myofascia and all
of these things
um inside in a way that is never the
same from time to time and so
you know a i think what she's doing is
extraordinary and i've been
um actually doing classes with her
remotely um
but also i would say that anyone who
feels that their best work is done
inside if they can't get into the moon
phases and the different you know the
biota and the
ways that the city sounds different when
the leaves are off the trees and all of
this although i would encourage you to
try
um figure out some way either try rev mo
revolution in motion or
um or figure out some way to inc
to introduce instability and
um imperfect control into your indoor
workouts yeah absolutely i'm thinking of
the
the balance board that we have two
directions you choose which direction
it's in stable
in but it's amazing you looking at it
you would think oh
you'll learn it and then you'll be
perfectly stable it's like nope there's
nothing you can do to be perfectly
stable there's enough
like jitter in your physiological
systems that you're always
in motion trying to stabilize and that's
i mean that's part of what i just
fell in love with stand-up paddle
boarding right away just like oh
oh you're just going to need to be on
even if there's no wind
and you know the current is ebbed and is
is is very slack and there's no yahoo
you know boats going by really fast
there's no way you still you just have
to be on
and you know being on for whatever you
know 30 minutes 60 minutes 90 minutes at
a time
is not something you're accustomed to
doing if you're just walking around
especially if you're
just sitting in a desk chair absolutely
all right so we will um we have a few
announcements at the end here but we
will be back at uh in 15 minutes
to answer your super chat questions as
we said at the beginning we now have
merch available at this
site teespring.com
podcast and if you use the code thankful
all caps
through the end of monday you get 15 off
if you want to become
either of our patrons um at patreon you
get 20
off also tomorrow is our monthly private
q a
at my patreon uh where we do a two-hour
q a with questions that have already
been submitted at this point
um for just for patrons of mine
um you can email the moderator
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
if there are other items that you think
you'd like like hats as brit talked
about early on
um it's a discord server that you can
access it's benefited both of our
patreon
patreons not this week but next week
you'll have your
um private ish semi-private
conversations at your patreon
that suggests it's about to be december
it's about to be december
exactly and um
[Music]
well we've got eclipse channel yep that
produces clips and uh
and we encourage you to subscribe to
that and subscribe to this and stick
around we'll take a 15-minute break you
might also like
and subscribe you should like notify and
if you like you should like
if you like you should like um and if
you have been unsubscribed which is this
diabolical thing that seems to happen
then
re-subscribe just you know check and
make sure you're still there
that's right that's right all right
everyone back soon yep we'll see in 15.
be well